we've got diamonds rose and dogs all of
them are here happy gamba and you've got
a new project world's most amazing dog I
mean my face it's been the most
incredible kind of experience it really
has because everybody submits he's
unbelievable videos of their dogs doing
the most incredible things so I just sit
there with George Lopez go oh my god
that cannot be true oh my god that's
fantastic and they're super smart some
of these dogs and they can't win
$100,000 if they win so it's you and
George Lopez are judging video
submissions
how many dogs yep I'm allegedly over the
city limit you know I have so many dogs
some only can bark Monday Wednesday
Friday and the rest of them on the
weekend it's pre-parole for people who
are submitting their videos what do
their dogs need to do to impress you to
get that check at the end well the
standard it's quite high I have to say
because some of these dogs I mean I
swear next year they can be stuck in the
dishwasher they're gonna bring him BT
embed these dogs I mean they're so smart
some of them open the fridge they get
the you know required like the beer out
the fridge I do all kinds of things and
some of them do like a plethora of
tricks you know so they're really very
very small okay we're gonna love it
would you submit any of your dogs
sleeping with a jug it wouldn't be there
how did this project come to you because
I mean you're a little bit busy so how
did you find time for this I am busy
but I always make time to do things I'm
crazy about and I'm too busy really to
vote from the valley from the rescue
center and rescue up 850 dogs or but if
it's something I'm passionate about yeah
it's been a great opportunity I've loved
every second bit so this show obviously
something that's making you happy
world's most amazing dog if you had to
describe it as a hybrid between other
shows what is it like well it's a
competition I think everybody enjoys
seeing man's best friend doing something
exceptional and funny stuff as well so
it's unlike any other show in that
respect but I think it's gonna be a big
hit I mean they've had thousands of
submissions to me it's kind of like
America's Funniest Home Videos meets
America's Got
and all about amazing dogs kind of yes
fair enough that's not bad
okay we'll run with that trap things up
here number one reason why we should
tune in to world's most amazing dog
because I think it's got such a
feel-good factor and it's quite
incredible the things they do I mean we
think of them as our pets but I also
think it really enlightens you as to
their talents and what they can do and
you know I was gobsmacked shocked what
he's in America like this town I like
gobsmacked I was back when I just watch
these videos and I thought how can this
dog be so smart but then we have seen
over these the you know cancer detecting
dogs the CNI dogs but to actually then
see it in the feel-good factor with the
fun they they have a lot of fun and they
really are something really talented
it's a fabulous show
[Music]